hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is the
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 12 say yes an episode that asked
us to say yes to catching up with riff
shown a magical CG idea
and our favorite trash person with
Steve's best negotiators killed 9:20 I
keep the cat we get you the gun we fight
together say yes yes however if you were
watching this episode closely there were
some really cool connections and
miserable details which I'm going to
point out in this video so let's get
started with the opening images ok this
opening montage shows Rick and Michonne
on this getaway together Gavin Jean food
and guns and making some time for
outside 11 and notice the music
throughout all this it's rhythmic and
intense kind of like heist music along
with the editing it makes Rick and
Michonne come off as cocky action heroes
for movies like we're obviously not
meant to feel worried about their safety
here and I think that reflects Rick and
Michonne a reckless state of mind
throughout this episode they're weirdly
cavalier when it comes to taking out
walkers and they seem less worried about
the upcoming war with negan than they
are about what comes after and there's a
reason for that which I'll talk about in
a bit but real quick notice pal when
Rick and Michonne go through the drawers
they leave this wad of cash behind it's
just a funny reminder how useful is
old-world currency is I also like the
subtle way that these scenes indicate
that these golfers are saviours closely
you can hear them mention fat Joey it's
hot here what was that damn word about
fat Joey and after Rick and Michonne
presumably killed them they're eating
the same brand of pretzels that we saw
white with last episode and later notice
when they come across this deer rick
says this line oh you were here this is
a reference back to episode 4 when
Michonne hunted the deer and rick handed
it off to negan along with her rifle
really pissing her off but when you
think about it this whole episode is
kind of structured like a date with rick
trying to make up to were shown how in
hecta Vande paralyzed by fear he's been
since meeting negan this is why he
wanted to stay out longer with Michonne
and why he was acting a bit more cocky
than usual then they encountered this
high school with the most interesting
mystery this episode what the hell
happened here
various happening yeah not very
specifically shown so this episode never
does quite say exactly but it's fun to
think about like the fact that there are
soldier walkers here make me think that
this is a school set up as a fema center
kind of like that school that Shane and
Otis went to in season 2 but as we see
in other moments this episode some
majors went down and before we go
further let's check back in with Rosita
while Rick is acting reckless out of his
love for Michonne Rosita is acting
reckless out of hate that woman is on a
warpath and notice how when Terra offers
her somebody to help her scar heals
Rosita refuses to remember Rose even
never really cared about getting a scar
on her face she inflicted it on herself
back in episode 8 by leaning into the
blade
so this scar is a symbol for the
unhealable wound in Rosita's heart like
since losing Abraham she'll never be at
peace until she has a revenge but then
later notice how the gun she goes after
it turns out to be a useless toy gun and
it's late almost like it's bait in a
trap so while the universe rewards
Rick's love inspired recklessness with a
cachet of guns it toys with Rosita so
naturally Rosita blames God or the
closest thing to God that she could find
Gabriel so stupid enough to listen to
you now I'll come back to Rosita but
this reckless attitude does not look
like she'll be able to truly heal the
pain in her heart ok moving back to Rick
and Michonne on the roof overlooking a
fairground and not only is it setting a
good place for like some creepy Walker
imagery a fairground is also a cliche
place for a date and that's exactly how
Rick and Michonne see it playing target
practice on this carnival game never
mind that's the whole point of this
mission is to scavenge valuable guns and
ammo but you know sure flush gold down
the toilet Michonne also I like the way
this episode calls back to key moments
that ended in failure for these people
first the roof caves in just like it did
and that awesome supermarket scene in
season 4 and then down below they find
this massive supply of food just like
Rick and Daryl found in season 6 but
whereas those moments ended in disaster
these moments and in super miraculous
win hi ok now moving on to their
candlelit dinner I found their
conversation interesting we can order
the world his way it's up to us to
reorder it once he's gone right I think
this line of thinking parallels history
in the way world
powers think about the future after Wars
for example as world war ii came to an
end with the defeat of Germany and Japan
the United States and the Soviet Union
realized that they were in a position to
realign the world either under a
democratic capitalistic worldview as the
Americans wanted or a communistic world
view as the Soviets wanted basically
history shows that afterwards one
there's still another battle to be
fought establishing your new world order
and maintaining it and I really think
history is inspiring Michonne post-war
thinking Rick assumes that all the
communities will just get along and a
power void but Michonne is right to say
no you have to lead that New World Order
Rick but then Rick's counter proposal to
have them reorder the world together is
really just a smooth move to shift the
conversation back to them like for Rick
this is all a chance to escape his
worries with this fund eight likes come
on baby let's just enjoy this freed
Strad armored food and real quick when
rick says that they can take their time
and won't need to fight negan
immediately I love how I mash own space
expresses what every Walking Dead viewer
felt in that moment like take our time
come on dude is what we've been doing
from 12 episodes let's get to it
okay moving on to this team with Tara
and Judith and man it really grew up
fast don't they
if Rick stays way longer he's going to
miss her first word she now that
bracelet was given to terrabytes Cindy
the girl who saved her an ocean side in
Episode six and last episode when Rick
asked her if she had found any guns
we saw Tara fidgeting with it so the
show is using this bracelet as a symbol
for Tara's loyalties to Oceanside and by
giving this bracelet over to Judith Tara
is freeing herself from this obligation
okay back to Rick and Michonne at the
fairground trying to divide up walkers
by using a car to block off a gate and
again it's interesting how even when
things don't go according to plan Rick
and Michonne aren't even fazed they're
still acting like this is all just a
date a post-apocalyptic zombie killing
date and they keep score about how many
walkers each of them has to kill kind of
like Legolas and Gimli in the two towers
[Music]
but all this fun comes to an abrupt halt
with this deer which can magically both
cast a shadow and be perfectly lit on
the same side so Rick makes another
reckless choice to get this deer as a
present for Michonne nearly killing
himself and then notice how all these
walkers have their hands tied up so why
is that and what does it tell us about
the serious things that went down here
well before I get to that I want to get
a quick shout out to our friends at
audible who helped us make this video
audible offers a wide selection of
audiobooks and you can get a free
audiobook with a 30-day trial at
audible.com slash new rock stars
so audible is great I use it to catch up
on all that's walk into a back story in
trivia sometimes I'll just listen to it
on a slightly faster speed while I'm
driving so that I can cram more in then
of course I end up driving slower
because I want to listen to more of it
and one audiobook that I really liked
was the walking dead rise to the
governor written by Robert Kirkman and
j-bone and singer and narrated by Fred
Berman who is awesome by the way he also
narrated Walking Dead search-and-destroy
which is amazing so yeah like me you can
turn your commute into something more
with a free trial at audible.com slash
new rockstars to start now okay back to
these walkers with their hands tied up
my theory is that this high school was
having a carnival when the zombie
outbreak began then FEMA came in to set
up a command center with Army soldiers
providing security but then the way
these things often go down civilians got
upset that they couldn't leave or that
they were being quarantined away from
their families or maybe the soldiers
were hoarding the food supply so the
civilians revolted and some got tied up
then it led to this huge gunfight with
soldiers getting run over by cars but
really these internet backstories are
one of my favorite things about this
show and I hope one day AMC makes an
anthology series where we get to see
each of these self-contained mini
episodes
kind of like what Frank Darabont's plan
was with that soldier in the tank and
the pilot episode okay it's this moment
when the reality of the danger that Rick
and Michonne are in finally becomes
clear this fake out with Rick appearing
to be eaten up by the walkers obviously
is it meant to trick the viewer like
seriously Rick isn't going to code down
like that forever no really it's meant
for Michonne like after all this cocky
romantic Walker decapitation and
or planning which surely needed to be
reminded what's at stake for this
current war they're gearing up for and
before week if it's awesome slow-motion
sword toss which kids you should never
do if the person isn't looking or even
if they are looking kids just don't
throw swords Rick miraculously again
crawls out of this box and I think this
is meant to call back another miraculous
resurrections when Glenn crawled out
from under the dumpster in season six
and I think these memories of Glenn are
meant to set up the next scene in the
van where Rick reveals that he's had
trouble sleeping ever since Glenn dies
man save me and Rick's speech - Michonne
is tied to the opposite of the Romantic
let's rule the world feel baby talk
earlier you can I can lose you it's
about a future so even though this is
kind of a grim thing to say to your
girlfriend this shows that rick is
thinking clearly waking up from his
escapist dream to finally look at the
big picture it also mirrors the
conversation that he had with Karl back
in season 2 people are gonna die
I'm gonna die mom
there's no way you can ever be ready for
it okay moving on to the scavengers in
the junkyard where Rick wins this
negotiation with jatis by quoting the
title this episode 20 I keep the cat get
you the guns we fight together say yes
and if you remember say yes was what
Jada said to end the negotiation with
Rick back in episode 10 one time this
time yes say yes now on the surface this
phrase doesn't really mean anything like
it's not really an argument it's just
please agree to the last thing said but
really it's a simple two-word phrase
that cuts through the back-and-forth and
urges the person across from you to step
back and look at the reality of what
you're gaining kind of like don't let
the perfect be the enemy of the good say
yes so that we can move forward together
and after terrorists seems to suggest
that she's going to tell Rick about all
the guns at Oceanside are closing images
show us Rosita and Sasha at the hilltop
and I love that Sasha already knows
exactly why we're Zita their hair
because I need your help one condition I
get to take the shot and much like the
history references with Rick and
Michonne earlier these two assassins
have a different approach to
international relations that also draws
on history like their goal is to
expedite the start of the war by
assassinating negan and this reminds me
of the shot heard around the world
phrase coined by poet Ralph Waldo
Emerson referring to the opening shots
of the American Revolution which I've
talked about in context with Rosita
before but also later the shot heard
around the world was also used to
describe the assassination of Austrian
Archduke Franz Ferdinand which triggered
the start of World War one by a rogue
militant group called the black hand so
while Rick and the others are saying
wait later tomorrow Rosita and Sasha are
saying now two former foes saying yes to
each other okay looking ahead to next
episode episode 13 titled bury me here
which is a reference to a grave someone
dug at the kingdom my guess is Richard
dug this as like a political statement
to Ezekiel suggesting that the kingdom
errs are expecting to die under his
oppressive deal with the saviors also
from the leaks theme Carol goes back
into badass mode finally as he charged
back into the kingdom looking for Morgan
it kind of seems like she found out
about her friends getting murdered by
negan and she's mad at Morgan for not
telling her even though that's exactly
what she told him to do and some
lingering question
do you think the walking dead whatever
ever really kill off Rick like you could
argue that this fake out death and his
conversation with Michonne and the van
for really an attempt to set up the
possibility of a world without Rick now
I don't honestly think The Walking Dead
would do this but let me know what you
think and to will Rosita and Sasha
survive this season like both of them
seem like they're on an insane suicide
mission here and they're going out of
the loan when as we've seen on this show
if you want to get anything done it has
to be the whole group working together I
also feel like they might be following
the Holly storylines in the comments
which I don't want to say anything about
in case them ends up happening but we'll
see okay let me know what you think in
the comments and check out all my other
breakdowns with season seven episodes
and thanks for watching and if you liked
this video please hit like and subscribe
to new rock stars also please share this
video and if you really like me rock
stars you can contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons you guys are the best
especially Matthew Sava you can hit me
up on Twitter at EA vas with any
thoughts you have on The Walking Dead or
if I love new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for updates on our videos
alright thanks for watching spike